Oh, what's up, beautiful people.
Let me bring some more people in the room.
How are we all doing? Good. Good, good, good, good, good.
Let me find the chat over here.
Um, all right, people still signing on?
Did you guys get an email this morning telling you
to join the call about, I don't know, five minutes ago?
Who got an email today? Anybody?
Let me check something real fast.
Uh, okay, perfect, perfect, perfect. All right.
Um, so, uh, man,
where do I start?
I don't even know where to start.
I didn't know you were down there. You doing?
I don't even know where to start, man. At the beginning.
Yeah, we're, we're beyond the beginning, man.
So, um, you guys might notice I was pretty aggressive this
weekend, and the reason why was
because I was taking attacks all weekend long.
People do not like what I'm out there doing at all.
They don't like it at all.
Uh, so I'm gonna, I'm, I'm gonna do it even more, right?
But, um, this is, this is pretty awesome you guys, man.
Um, I, I'm gonna tell you right now, I am, uh,
spending a lot of money.
I mean, a lot of money so that you guys don't have to.
And, um, this week, uh,
I I think it's pretty awesome that
we're gonna continue this week.
Uh, and the reason why, uh, pne, can you check
that email, make sure it went out.
Uh, oh. I'm, I'm not only, yeah, poking the bear.
I am stomping the bear, right?
It, it doesn't get more hairy Carey than this, right?
Um, so, uh, this weekend, um,
I started something, I, I had a huge epiphany moment.
So this is, this is what's kind of cool guys,
and I'm sure that you would agree.
And by the way, I'm gonna ask for
your help with this stuff, right?
Um, that, uh, people are still out there trying
to figure out how to install this thing.
Are you guys seeing this in all the groups?
People are where, where can I get this installed?
This stops, where can this stop
where, and blah, blah, blah, blah.
People are still trying to figure out how to install it.
We're already light years ahead.
We've already figured out how to train ais, how to, how
to get it to do all these actions, how to get it
to build courses and send out emails
and like, we're light years ahead.
But you know what? This weekend I got even further ahead,
light years ahead,
and when you guys see what I'm about to show you,
you're gonna, you're gonna flip out.
You're, you're gonna, you're gonna, I'm telling you, it,
this was the greatest opportunity for those of you
that joined the Claw program.
For those of you that joined the Mastermind.
When you see what I'm about to do,
and by the way, I think that I'm gonna, when it's all said
and done, I think it's gonna cost me about $3,000 to get it
to where I want to get it to, okay?
And the reason why I'm doing that is
so that you don't have to do that.
So let me explain something real quick, alright?
On a scale of one outta 10,
how familiar do you guys think you are with the models?
Now, I'm talking about obviously, uh, the, the,
the open AI was the first one we started dealing with.
And now you learn, learned about Anthropic,
and you've learned about CLA and you learned about Moonshot,
and you've learned about Gemini
and like, where are you at on a scale of one out of 10?
How, how familiar are you?
And you're starting to understand when to use what.
Like, I'm sure that you guys learned
that Moonshots Kimmy 2.5 build does not build
apps at all, right?
Uh, and I'm sure you're starting to understand when
to use Opus 4.5 versus Sonnet four point.
Like you're starting to understand that stuff, okay?
So there's gonna be this big clarification that I get
to make in the world.
That's pretty awesome. All right?
So, um, you can do, like I'm doing right now,
my developers share a Claude subscription
that costs us $200 a month.
And with that, we're rebuilding Mint Bird,
where creates a full blown sales page and you can edit it.
We're rebuilding, uh, you know, uh, pop links
with the pages that you choose there.
We're rebuilding, quiz forma,
rebuilding the layouts in Letterman and everything else.
And, and we get to build as much software as we want
for $200 a month.
Alright, cool, that's a great deal, right?
So you're, if you're gonna build apps
or whatever else, you're much better off doing that.
However, what have I been telling you about the future?
That the days of logging into a software
and then creating this campaign and doing this
and doing that are gone.
So what happens is, if you're using the software like we do,
uh, even if you're using Cloud Code to go
and build out all these apps
and everything, if you want it to work with Open Claw,
what do you have to have?
What do you have to have?
You have to have an API, you have to have APIs,
you have to have API docs.
So now you gotta go another level. Make sense?
So yeah, do like, we're doing, use cloud code build apps.
It's incredible, right? But for it to work with
Open Claw has to have an API so it can go in the back end
because we know that if it opens up a browser,
because can spend a lot of money on tokens, okay?
So we know that. Yeah, but you agree, we know that.
All right, so let me ask you a question.
If I'm building apps with Open Claw,
I'm not able to use My Claw subscription, by the way,
people started posting, uh, misinformation
and they started posting out there that, um, you know,
it's against Claude's terms of service to use Open Claw
and Claude's gonna shut you down
and you're gonna lose your account.
Blah, blah, blah, blah. No, it's all bs.
Read it very carefully.
What Claude is saying is that they don't want you
to use your 200 month subscription,
$200 month subscription with Open Claw.
Claude wants you to do what we're doing.
Use your open AI keys,
or I'm sorry, use your a, your Anthropic keys.
That's what it wants you to do. It does not want you.
And there's ways to get around it.
And I'm not gonna tell you guys that, 'cause
I don't want you to get in trouble.
It does not want you using their subscription on third party
services, like open on a scale of one outta 10.
Does everybody understand that? Does everybody get that?
So let me ask you a question.
Really me this Batman, if we can go and open up
and, and use clock code to build whatever software we want,
you guys see people doing it all over their wall,
people are building apps and software and everything else.
Why in the world would we be building software inside
of Open Claw spending tokens?
And I can't stand it when people go
and pacey big, long things here.
Joshua, you're making my life difficult today.
Answer the question. Why would we be
spending tokens?
Why, why would we open up Open Claw
and spend hundreds of dollars a day building this out when
we can do cloud code for $200 a month?
Why? Somebody tell me the reason why.
If you're silly, no.
Whoever, whoever user is, gets it.
See, here's the thing.
When Open Cloud builds an app, it knows
how to use it.
Got it? How many of you just connected the dots?
When Open Claw builds an app, I'm gonna say it again.
It knows how to use it. You don't have to train it.
It built it from the ground up. It built it.
So does it cost money? Yeah. Oh yeah.
Especially when you see what I'm about to show you.
Y'all are about to fall outta your chair
with what I'm about to show you.
But first, let me show you the downside.
So if I open up my email, uh, you can see
that Anthropic is having a heyday with me.
This is built with sonnet 4.5.
Sometimes I bounce into Opus if I can't get somewhere,
but you can see that boom, boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Uh, we're gonna spend a lot of money.
It's gonna cost us about three K.
Not only are we doing this here, um, I'm gonna show you, um,
I'm gonna give you guys a sneak peek,
what's coming up in the 2.0 version
of the open claw shadow intensive.
But in addition to here, I'm now also starting
to spend money over here in Versal.
Now, when you start setting up databases
and everything, that's where you start spending money.
I'm gonna shoot videos showing you guys all
this stuff, okay?
But the bottom line is, my, my big, um, uh, I idea
that I'm trying to show you guys right now is I am spending
a lot of money so that you don't have to.
And so the team, uh, showed up today
and they showed up with a big surprise.
And I gave them an incredible mission, an incredible task.
I said this week, hold on, let me find your comments.
'cause I want you guys to see that I said this week,
everything that is on the screen, we are going to deploy
inside of our members verse account.
So that everything you see here, that beautiful video board
that we showed you, where you go and you approve
and you reject that video board, the command center,
the, uh, let me come over here, let me open up this one.
Here's your, your control panel that we created
with a task over here on the side.
Some people are struggling with this.
And, and then you come over here and,
and you have all your commands that we're creating
with our software, right?
All of this stuff here. Uh,
your article board, look at this here, guys.
Look at the article board. This is where it goes.
And finds the articles for you by category West Valley.
Save the Doggy.
If you wanna look at it in like a card format.
Are you guys seeing this right now?
Everything that I am building
and perfecting the idea board
where you can tell open claw, Hey, I got an idea.
Make sure you store it in the board.
Or how about bookmarks online that you find?
Or how about a wishlist?
You watch a webinar, you see an ad, you're like, man,
I gotta buy that this weekend.
Add it to my wishlist.
Or how about just keeping track of your projects?
Or how about this one?
How many of you have ever heard me talk about plaquey
and how it is the most incredible,
the most incredible project center of all time?
Well, what if I told you I went and rebuilt Plaquey?
You see this? And I can come over here
and I can add images to the task and everything else, right?
I can come over here and look at, look at this guys.
So all of this stuff we are going to deploy
for you, and I'm not done.
We're gonna keep going this whole entire thing.
You are gonna have your own domain.
You are gonna have your own software.
Now here's what's amazing about this man.
See, it's gonna be a base for you to start
where you guys don't have spend the money
that we are spending, okay?
But guess what? Open Claw is gonna have
access to the repository.
It is gonna be able to make changes for you.
So if there's something I did, maybe you don't have a team,
uh, it it, let me show you again here.
If you look up at the top, look at this guys.
If you look up here at the top, you know,
if I just wanna see my task, if I wanna see G's task,
Brene's task, whatever, I can do that.
If I wanna create a new task, I can do that.
But it can do all of this on its own as well, right?
So here's the thing, man, maybe you don't have a team, okay?
So you tell Open Claw, Hey, do me a favor, remove the team.
Maybe you don't wanna have projects like I do.
Maybe there's stuff here that you don't like.
Well, guess what? You can go
and tell Open Claw to remove it on a scale of one outta 10.
Does everybody understand this right now?
So the team is figuring out right now how do we package
that up so that you can deploy it in your Elle account?
And on top of that, you have the skills inside
of Open Claw where it is using the software for you.
Anybody excited with that at all?
I worked hard on this this weekend for you guys
when I realized that
and I realized like the rest
of the market's still out there trying to figure out how
to install this damn thing.
We've already figured out how to use the APIs, how
to use third party services, how to connect it with our
software, how to build links and pages.
And we've already figured out all that stuff.
But now I not only figured out how to build the software
that it can run on its own,
but now I figured out how
to have it all right there in one simple control panel
that you can use, your team can use,
and more importantly, open Claw can use.
Does that make sense? Yeah, you're way behind. Josh.
Does that make sense to everybody?
How many of you're starting to get this now?
So I'll give you the base,
you'll be able to use it right away.
Open Claw. Your open claw will be able to use it right away.
But you can keep building on the base.
You can change the base, you can tear down the base.
It will be your own software.
Install that Open Claw can control
and it's gonna cost me a lot of money
to get it to the finish line.
I've been, uh, uh, I won't show you the stuff
that I've been doing, but I've been laying in bed.
Um, um, you know, I'm, I'm over here working on the desktop,
trying to perfect everything for you guys.
And then I go to bed and I open up Telegram
and I start, uh, I keep working at it from bed, right?
Because I got my phone in front of me.
So I'm like, no, this has gotta be that.
You gotta fix this button, you
gotta make this, gotta make that.
And what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to make it, uh,
perfectly, uh, responsive for you guys.
See, it doesn't come responsive outta the gate.
It does pretty good, but it definitely does not come
responsive outta the gate, right?
So is there anybody excited with this?
We're to deploy that whole thing for you,
that whole thing.
So let me show you, um, what we've put together, uh,
and, and I gotta meet with, uh, Matt on this.
These are all, um,
these are all things that, uh, will be added to 2.0.
So here's the thing guys.
We are doing a webinar this Thursday.
I'm, I'm putting my footprints out there, man.
I'm, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
I don't care what anybody says. We're putting a webinar out
there this Thursday.
And so obviously this date is just a placeholder right now.
We're just trying to get it approved.
But you can see that we have the shadow intensive 2.0
that you guys are going to be a part of.
Obviously you don't have to worry about the VPS install.
Um, but now here's the new thing.
The open clock control board, you see this? Guess what?
You guys already have it. This is what I just showed you.
We're, we're gonna do that for you this week.
You guys are gonna be our beta users for this.
Does that make sense? Time to chat.
Let me know if everybody gets this right now.
Let me know if everybody gets this.
We come down here, the open claw skills vault.
So somebody was asking, where can I go?
We're gonna put all the skills that we've done in one place,
the open claw micro SaaS accelerator.
I'm gonna spend three days during 2.0
where it is only focused on creating apps with open cloth.
Okay? So that's gonna be a three day intensive where we go,
we set up your repository the right way.
We set up your Elle, I teach how to create databases, how
to add the domains, all of that stuff there,
the different models to use, okay?
All of that will be covered there.
Obviously the members area is being beefed up.
And then these people will get the basic access
of the titanium suite.
Now guys, this is going
to be a 9 97 offer on this webinar.
And it's yours. It's yours.
Even if you came in at the 4 97 deal
or whatever, you get to participate in 2.0.
Uh, and you get to get everything here on the screen.
So thank you so much
for putting your trust into us When we dove into something
that, uh, we knew very little about, but we were dedicated
and put ourselves in the box
and we're really, really focused on it.
That's my way of saying thank you for giving me
that base to start with.
Is that cool? Is that cool?
So when you watch this webinar Thursday,
I need you guys to back me up.
Uh, I need you to talk about how great it is when I say,
do we have anybody that's gone through the shadow intensive?
Can you guys do that for me?
I need you to do that one thing
and I need you to do something else too.
And it's really, really important guys, more than ever
before, if you knew the attacks I was getting out there,
my God, um, this, this post right here though,
I made this post right here, okay?
And I need you guys to comment about how excited you are,
whether it be the control board, whatever.
But can you guys, if you haven't commented already,
or even if you had commented, I don't care,
can you do me a favor and just blow this up
because I wanna get three or 400 comments
before we do that webinar on Friday.
Can you guys do that for me?
So let me come over here
and lemme go ahead and share this post.
Uh, that's all I need you to do.
I just need you to show up on the webinar.
Don't buy a thing, light up my posts when you see them.
And I'm gonna tell you right now, I if it,
if it's a fair trade, I'm gonna keep spending the money.
I'm gonna keep building out the assets for you
and we're just gonna keep handing them over.
And all I need you to do is just go on my wall talking about
how this whole experience has been incredible.
Is that a fair trade? Let me know if that's fair.
Is that a fair trade for everybody?
Josh just says, on a scale of one out of a hundred,
do you guys think that's a fair trade?
Craig says, hell yes.
Alright, so do me a favor, do that guys.
We need your help. We need your help with this, right?
Um, there's a lot of people that are out there trying
to sell $1,500 packages and $3,000 packages
and I kind of ruined it for 'em.
Uh, because what happens is they're going into those posts,
there's an ad out there running right now.
They're going into those posts
and they're saying, well, why would I pay you five,
$1,500 if Chad nicely did it all for free?
And he did this and he did that and he did this.
And I, I'm reaching out to people like, dude, you're,
you're getting me destroyed.
That's what's happening right now.
People are trying to capitalize on it and we went
and did it all for free except the, the, the, you know,
two weeks or whatever.
Um, and so we're getting destroyed out there.
I don't know if you know that or Matt, Matt,
I don't know if you've seen that We're getting destroyed.
People are not liking what we're doing, right?
So that's okay.
I said from the very start,
we're gonna take care of our customers.
That's it. That's what we're doing. Not the partners.
You're gonna take care of our customers.
So, uh, help me out with those posts please,
guys, when you see it.
Um, and I'm, I'm trying to teach a mastermind too, how to,
uh, capitalize on a shiny object and,
and, you know, scream from the rooftops.
So I'm trying to show them too.
So please watch my wall when you see things,
man, blow it up for me.
Please blow it up. Okay?
Um, so now you know that, um,
this is taking place.
Now let me show you something else too. Alright?
The biggest complaint I see, and I might need your help, g
'cause I haven't done it in a couple days
and I'm so overwhelmed.
Um, I'm gonna go ahead and log into my VPS here
and the biggest complaint I see from people, okay,
so I'm logged into a VPS.
Um, the biggest complaint I see from people is
that open claw, uh, tries to switch to a different model.
And when it does, when it does,
it comes up with something like Claude 3.5
or something and it breaks.
Has anybody seen that issue at all?
I've seen it a couple times in the WhatsApp group.
I had it happen to myself a couple times.
So I'm gonna show you how to get into your config file.
And like I said, gee, I might need your help on this.
So this is the open claw gateway dashboard, okay?
And, um, uh, uh, Steven, didn't we fix you on Friday?
You had your hand up Friday,
nobody fixed you, can you mute please?
Steven Pond talk.
Yeah. Hi there. Can you hear me
Friday, right? Nobody
fixed you.
Yeah, well he, at that point in time,
Gura was talking about, uh, having the open table broken.
And, um, so I waited
and sometime during, uh, Saturday, uh, it came back,
but then, uh, I went out.
I'll admit it, I broke it. I went to the, uh,
So Friday we had you fixed though, right?
We had you fixed Friday. No,
It, it took, it took you, I didn't see it back
until the Saturday sometime.
Yeah, because the, a air table was down
and you couldn't get your credential.
Oh, the table was down on track. That's
Right. Like there's no problem
there. But I broke it again.
Um, I tried to, I tried to put in, uh, AI rotor, okay?
And, um, I asked, uh, my, my open claw guy Stanley, to, uh,
You gotta be careful. Wait,
wait till, wait till we give you those commands
because if we give you guys a command,
we have already broken in a hundred times
before we give you that command.
Does that make sense? I understand.
I know that, I know people wanna install the new
Gemini and everything else.
We'll wait till we break it first guys,
and then we'll give you a command
where you'll give it your API key and the command
and then it won't break.
Okay? Does that make sense?
The adding the models right now is really, really touchy.
All right, I'm gonna show something that's gonna help right
now, um,
but wait till we get the commands on new things, guys.
We're, if you guys understood how much money we're spending,
how much we're testing everything for you so
that you don't break, you would understand, right?
So, well I understand. We'll, uh,
the open router thing is a good thing.
We're testing that this week.
Um, Steven, that actually came from one
of my VIPs that had that.
I'd never heard of that before. We'll have
that tested this week, okay?
But in the meantime, we now have air. It wasn't us down.
Airtable was down on Friday.
We couldn't get anybody's credentials. So we're good now, G.
Yeah, we're good. Okay.
So maybe pne or somebody can help him real quick.
Yeah. Okay, perfect. We'll get you set up Steve.
Alright. And anybody else that is completely down
that can't figure it out, put your hand up,
let us go fix you.
Let us just go log in and we'll fix you.
We're pretty good at fixing things.
We're good at breaking things, but that's
because we wanted to get good at breaking things
so we could get good at fixing things.
Okay? So I'm over here
inside the open claw gateway dashboard, all right?
Um, and if I were to come over here,
let me see if I can show you, uh, I'm sure
that you guys have started learning how to get into your,
uh, power shell and you run as an administrator.
Okay? So this is where I taught you guys in a video.
We can come over here and do Open clock gate, uh,
gate way, restart.
That's the most obvious one when it freezes.
The other one is we can do open claw doctor space, dash,
dash, uh, repair.
And then I think the other one is Doctor Fix, right?
G I'm going off memory.
I always do repair, but the other one's fix, right?
Yeah, yeah. Or we could do Doctor Fix.
Now, 90% of the time
that will fix issues when Open Claw has problems.
All right? On a scale of one outta 10,
does everybody understand this right now,
I wanna make sure everybody gets this.
This will not fix the problem
when Open Claw says, okay, I've switched to Kimmy 800,
and then all of a sudden you get
this message saying it's broke.
And here's the reason why.
Open Claw just attempted to switch
to a model that doesn't exist.
And so now there's no way for us to restart it
because it's trying to use a model that doesn't exist.
But I'm gonna show you how we fix that. Okay?
So the other thing is, if we can never get this dashboard
open, we can do open claw dashboard just like this,
and then your dashboard will open up, okay?
Very, very basic commands.
There's other ones, we have 'em in the guide,
but that's kind of what you guys need to know right now.
All right? Is everybody clear on that? There's my dashboard.
Okay? And the other thing I showed you is a lot
of times if you get Google Open, you come up here
and you can see a previous history.
Like if I come over here and type in like chat
or something, I can usually see my dashboard here too.
And that's another way to open it. All right?
So once we have this open, if we come down here to settings
and we go over here to config, all right?
Um, uh, if we scroll through here,
let me see if I can get it over here.
So you're gonna see
that the menu changes over here on the left
hand side, right?
But I'm just kind of scrolling through real quick
and showing you, uh, where we can get the same exact thing
that you click over here, uh, takes you down here, okay?
So what happens is you have all of your models down here.
I don't remember, is it under G or let me do this.
I'm gonna hit control F
and, uh, let me just see if I can do a search for, yeah,
okay, so it's right here, it is under agents.
And see how this one says order fallback model.
So here's what I'm gonna do. Instead of searching
for Kimmy, right?
I'm gonna go to the very, very top
and I'm gonna hit control F, which opens up this window,
and I'm gonna search for fallback.
And it's not gonna be this one, it's not gonna be this one,
it's not gonna be this one.
It's not this one, it's this one.
See here. So we're over here in this area
with your different models, okay?
So what's gonna happen is,
and it did it this weekend, it said, I have switched to
Claude Sonnet 2.5 and it broke.
And this has happened to a lot of people.
So what I did was I came in here
and I searched for Claude Sonnet 2.5,
and it took me to this section right here that,
and it said Claude Sonnet 2.5.
And all I did was I went
and changed it back to four dash five, okay?
And once I did that, I restarted the gateway
and I was back online on a scale of one out of 10.
Does everybody understand this right now?
But here's what I want you to do,
and I'm gonna see if we can do this
during the onboarding process.
G see where it says ordered fallback models
used when the primary model fails.
So look, I'm gonna give you guys this right here.
I'm gonna post this in the chat.
You should probably do this right now.
I'm gonna come back up to the top.
I'm gonna show you how we get to this again, okay?
I'm gonna close this. So I'm in the setup wizard, right?
So I'm over here, settings config.
I'm gonna hit control F
and paste that line when the primary model fails.
Okay? And here it is right here.
And what you wanna do is you wanna make sure that you have
Moonshot slash Kimmy 2.5.
Does everybody understand this right now?
This is what you wanna have.
So if it tries to do like Claude three point 10
or whatever the heck, and I don't know why it's doing that,
by the way, when you restart it, boom,
we come back over here to the fallback model.
Does that make sense to you guys?
I wanna make sure everybody gets this.
So now look, you can start to understand
what our onboarding process is.
Um, if you start to scroll through here, uh,
you'll see, hold on, lemme close this, close these things.
It's kind of weird how it does this.
Uh, you'll see all the different models. See 'em.
Now, do not try
to add your own models in here.
Don't do it this way. You'll break it.
Let us do the commands for you.
But if it's broke, make sure that
your default one, wherever that went, make sure your,
your default one is set, okay?
And then whenever it does something weird, like Claude 500
or whatever, go find Claude 500
and change it back to where it was.
So if I was you guys, I, I just came up
with this, I would come in here.
Yeah, I'll do the process again, Kenny.
Uh, if I was you guys, I would go ahead
and take a screenshot, see how I have all the models here.
I would just come over here and I would take a screenshot.
And that way you know
what these custom entries should always be.
Save it somewhere. Save it.
And now if it breaks, you can always get back in here
and you can repair it.
You don't wanna do an un
uninstall, you don't wanna do none of that.
So open claw, gateway, restart, open claw, doctor space,
dash v, open claw doctor space slash slash repair.
And if it's something with your API keys,
or I'm sorry if it's something with the AI model,
now you know where it has stored those, those details.
And now we can do a fix.
Does everybody understand this right now?
So I'm gonna show you one more time.
I'll just come over here and I'll click on debug
and I'll come back over here to config.
So I click on config, I'm over here on the setup wizard,
and for me, I'm gonna hit control F
and that opens up this little window here.
And then what I told you guys is I gave you the exact title
of what I want you to search for.
So you're gonna go ahead and search for this right here.
And it's this guy right here.
Make sure, see under Model Fallbacks, make sure
that this says Moonshot slash Kimmy 2.5.
Now here's the thing, you don't wanna do
that if you didn't install the moonshot API
Key 'cause it's gonna break.
And so then what would you do?
Well, you'd probably make this the default
of probably this guy here.
Okay? You'd probably take that
and you would probably make this your default.
So we would go ahead and put it there, just like that.
And then you save. All right.
Does everybody got this?
It's gonna save a lot of problems for you guys.
A lot of problems.
Uh, gee, is there anything that you want to add on that?
Uh, not on this one,
but yeah, this is a good way
to do it from the browser itself without, without having
to know all the commands.
Yeah. Pretty cool, right? Yeah.
Is there, um, anything else
that they need to be aware of in here?
Not really, and not in these model of fallback ones. Um,
Yeah, I wanna keep it pretty simple.
Yeah. Um,
let me show you guys something else too.
Um, there's a lot of rate limits
that are happening
and let me see if I can get into, um,
uh, I can never remember the freaking
set up a pop link, but I can't remember.
Um, so, uh,
when we come in here,
is it our nicely media G or is it our, my name?
Um, it's uncharted nicely.
Okay, so lemme show you guys something.
Uh, I screwed up. Hold on a second.
I did not spell my name right. Uh, reload.
Okay.
All right, hold on just a minute guys.
Let me, uh, do this for my phone.
Experiencing delivery issues. Oh, I got it.
Sign in the Claude.
Okay, I wanna show you something I think is gonna solve a
lot of problems here too.
3 5 0 3 1 8.
Okay, 3 5 0 3 1 8. Okay.
Verify email address. All right, so, uh,
when you're over here and they're all
kind of different, right?
Uh, so I'll come over here to my name
and then settings, I believe.
Yeah. And then you got your building and everything else.
This is for the API keys, right? G Or is it another spot?
I think it's another spot, yeah.
Yeah, you have to go to platform blog, AI
Platform.
How do you remember that? I used to remember stuff like
that when I was your age too.
Platform dot Claude ai, right?
Yeah. All right.
Lemme just look in Google to see why that didn't open.
Yeah, just says for, uh, platform,
cloud platform or something.
Uh, should be on the top though.
It's anthropic though, right? Yeah. Is it this one?
No, that's Claude. Is it this
One? Uh, try that one.
Let me see if I can
give you the direct link.
Yeah, it's confusing. I think it is this one.
Or maybe this
Try this one platform.com instead of ai.
All right. platform.com.
Dot com. Yeah. So confusing.
All right, um,
hold one second.
So this is a different place now.
1, 2, 5, 9, 5, 4.
Okay, so I should have had this in the videos,
but I didn't exactly understand it like I do now
over here on the side where it says Manage guys,
there's something called Limits
and see where it says rate limit.
We need everybody to be at least tier two.
Can you tell me what your tier is?
If you're using Claude, which you will, we need everybody
to be tier two, or you will hit rate limits.
Okay? So can you guys go log to here, I guess,
and tell me what your rate limit is?
You can see that we're over here on tier four,
why we're spending a lot of money, right?
I don't know how many tiers there are,
but uh, you definitely want to be on tier two.
So Matt's on tier two. Who else?
Two. If you're on one
and you're using Claude, you are going to hit
rate limits, okay?
Now, the way that you get to tier two,
we're telling all our VIPs, we're saying, Hey,
you gotta go spend 40 bucks.
You gotta put $40 in your billing,
and once you spend $40, you're at tier two,
and then you won't hit those limits as much.
Um, gee, can you tell me why else people are
hitting limits like that?
Uh, I don't think there's any other reason,
but when you try to start using it, let's say you loaded $5
and then we start the onboarding process,
or any other process that we go through in the open cloud.
Yeah, the token, it uses, uh, increases, right?
And there's a very small limit for that, okay?
Like, they encourage you to always go to tier two.
Okay? So Mark Jovin, he's the only one that's at tier one.
You're, you're gonna have problems.
So go to your, um, wherever you, you,
you add that, like your limits or your, your billing
or wherever and set it up.
See, I only have a $16 remaining balance,
but, uh, add $40 there.
If, if you got 20 there, add 20 more, like whatever.
You just need to get to 40. Okay?
So, uh, I have a feeling you're probably pretty close
and then you'll hit tier two
and then we'll get past, uh, the rate limit when it comes
to Claude, right?
I have not seen, um, a rate limit, uh, when it comes
to Kimmy or anything.
Most of the time guys, uh,
we are building from Kimmy two point,
or I'm sorry, most of the time we're running Kimmy 2.5.
This weekend when I was building all that stuff out
for you guys, I was using, uh,
Claude's sonnet 4.5 all weekend.
And it was just Chaching, chaching,
chaching, chaching, chaching.
Connie was freaking out,
what the hell is this philanthropic thing?
I said, what do you mean? So I keep getting emails,
they're charging 25, 25, 25.
What are you doing in there?
You're supposed to be making money, not spending money.
I said, no, no, no, this is gonna be good.
You gotta trust me on this, right?
So, um, yeah, Kim,
E 2.5 is gonna do a crappy build.
It's gonna frustrate you.
You're gonna use some four letter words.
So we don't try to use Kim E 2.5 to, uh, build apps.
We don't use Kim E 2.5 to train them.
You can a little bit,
but when you start getting into heavy, heavy stuff,
like when we did the re-engagement and stuff mm-hmm.
You're gonna probably switch to, um, I,
I very rarely use Opus.
Most of the time I'm on sonnet.
So everything that I built this weekend was with Sonnet.
Okay? So I need to always have at least 40.
No, no, just get to tier two and you'll be good.
You get to tier two, you can put five bucks in there.
It don't matter, right?
But just remember guys, how many of you are now starting
to become familiar when you're gonna change to what model?
You guys starting to understand this now,
and we're gonna add Gemini in there
and there's gonna be more models coming up.
You know, we tried a free model that was just, you get
what you pay for, it was garbage,
but the free models will be there, right?
So the,
the big dog obviously is Opus, Opus 4.5.
Now, Opus 4.6 is out there,
but people are not real happy with it.
So right now, Opus 4.5 is a big dog in our world.
So if we're gonna do something heavy, heavy processing
and we don't have the patience,
we don't wanna be frustrated, right?
Then you're probably just gonna switch to Opus 4.5, get
that thing trained, get it to memory,
and then go back to Kimmy for building the kind
of apps that I built this weekend.
Like I said, I didn't need Opus 4.5, I could do all of
that on Sonnet 4.5, which is way less than Opus.
So very rarely, I I pretty much use,
look, sonnet will get you there,
but there might be some revisions.
So if I'm starting to lose patience
and it's 11 o'clock at night and I'm tired
and I just wanna get this damn mobile thing done,
then I'll say, screw you switch to switch to Opus 4.5.
I had enough of this b******t, right?
Like all, and so then it switches, then I get the job done,
then I get to go to sleep, right?
Once I get the job done, I come off of Opus.
I'm very rarely on Opus guys, to be honest with you.
Very rarely. So Sonnet will do the training,
sonnet will definitely do the apps, okay?
But for running day to day,
four slash pop link four slash email,
four slash leads dev four slash for running day to day,
guys, Kimmy 2.5 is good enough.
Y'all got that. Now, how many
of you're under, just type the chat.
I understand if you're getting this,
and the only way you're gonna really understand it is
to start playing with this.
It's the only way you're gonna understand it.
But what I have found is that when you're running Kimmy,
it'll get cheaper and it'll get cheaper.
Now, why? Because there's gonna come a, a Kimmy, uh, 4.5
or a Kimmy 1 58, 1 78, whatever,
and it's gonna be the most expensive one,
and then 2.5 will go down in cost.
That's how these things work. And then eventually they'll
depreciate it like we saw with chat, g chat, chat,
GBT 4.0, right?
That's gonna happen, okay?
So, uh, always understand the options
that you have available and, um,
when you're gonna use what.
Okay? Now, um,
I'm gonna tell you right now, I have two launches scheduled.
So I have a webinar this Thursday that I would like you guys
to be there and be present,
but don't buy as good as it's gonna sound.
Don't buy it. Just support us, okay?
Give us a lot of comments, blow it up.
We'll be taking screenshots.
Um, and the reason why is,
'cause I got two launches coming up.
One on JV Zoo, one on Warrior Plus,
and we're trying to pull a miracle out of the seat
of our pants here to make this happen.
Um, but, uh, we're going to make it happen.
So this webinar this week is very important.
So we can go back to the partners
and say, look how well we did all this webinar
with this offer, right?
And, and that's, and so that's my thank you to you.
You get everything that you're gonna see on Thursday,
but I also think it's gonna help you really understand the
importance of this, okay?
Um, at the same time, I'm gonna tell you right now that, uh,
my buddy Nick is hitting the stages like something fierce,
and he's gonna go out there
and he's gonna sell this thing, okay?
At the same time, I got a guy that some of, you know,
we call him Magic Mondo,
the laziest entrepreneur on the planet
that I was on the phone with this morning.
He said, bro, you're ahead
of the curve again, gimme the rundown.
'cause I don't understand this stuff, but I got people
reaching out to me, they hear what you're
doing, what are you doing?
So I can sell this thing on the phone.
So I told him, and I said, Hey man,
you could just sell the install alone,
like ab Sumo selling it for 1500 bucks.
We got this magic onboarding process.
So then, and I should have realized this, I always get very,
very valuable information from Armando,
because he was the first one to say,
your students just want you
to push the button for 'em, Chad.
And that kicked off the workshop.
Well, now students just want me to give him commands,
audio commands that they can use, right?
Like it's, it's starting to evolve.
Um, but he was also the first one to tell me, uh,
'cause I would get all techy with him, you know, uh,
this is 10 years ago.
And he would say, bro, stop it. What do they want?
I said, what do you mean? I said, it could do this.
You could load a spreadsheet, it could create a course,
it could do, nah, nah, nah, I don't care about that.
What do they want? I said, no, you don't understand.
It's really, really cool. We built, I don't care about that.
What do they want? And I got quiet and I learned a lot.
And I learned about the opportunity.
I learned about, uh, sell the future,
not the features, right?
I learned all those things from him.
So he hits me up this morning, he goes,
dude, I know you're ahead of the curve.
I know you got a shiny object on your case.
Yes, I'm watching your wall. He turned 40 yesterday.
So we had a little bit of a conversation.
He goes, time for me. He go sell this thing.
I said, all right. He goes, gimme the rundown.
So what do you wanna know? So he starts asking questions,
I start answering, all right, well,
let's find the opportunity in this thing, right?
And so he was walking through all these cases.
So, can I go out there and can I do prospecting for you?
Can I do this? Can I do that? Can I do this? Can I do it?
Can I do that? And I can do all this stuff.
So I'm gonna hop on a call with him
later, but here's what he says.
And it got me thinking.
It got me thinking about everything I did with Karthik,
everything that I did with Nick, uh,
and everything that I would do if somebody said, here,
I just collected, and this is what Armando's gonna do.
I just collected $15,000 from this person.
Let's do a deep dive and let's
build this out for their business.
Is there anybody that would be interested in
talking about this right now?
Anybody? Is anybody interested in learning how
to go out there and sell this thing
and not only sell this thing, um, but actually go out there
and deliver this thing?
So what I'm gonna do is,
is it okay if I give you guys a snapshot?
What is coming up on Thursday?
Are you guys okay if I give you a sneak peek,
even though I'm not done with it yet?
Is that okay? Because there's some points here
that I really wanna drive home that I think are important
to set this up before, um,
before I teach you how to deliver this thing, okay?
So let me show you what is going to happen on Thursday.
So the first thing that we want to emphasize,
all right, is this right here.
If you thought you missed a train,
you're at the exact moment, uh, where the power shifts.
And by the way, are we seeing the slide
or are we seeing the presenter view GI wanna show them the
slide, not the presenter view.
I think it's the presenter view.
Of course it is. Okay, hold on a second.
Stop share screen. Okay, I'm gonna do it over here.
Now, share screen. Okay, how about now?
Uh, still the same.
What? You're not just seeing one whole slide.
You're seeing a bunch of slides at the bottom.
No, it looks like the slide to
me. I'm just seeing the train.
Okay, perfect. All right.
And, and, and by the way, this, uh, a lot
of this presentation guys was created with camera ai.
But anyways, um, if you thought you missed a train,
you're at the exact moment where the power shifts.
So what does that mean? It means
that people have been playing around, okay?
They've been playing with Chad, GBT, uh,
I've seen some people go on their wall making action figures
with Midjourney and stuff like that, blah, blah.
Everybody's playing not no more.
Um, so if you are worried that you got behind
with vibe code and everything else, don't worry.
None of that mattered right? Now.
What matters is right now, this is the exact moment
where you need to pay attention, right?
And here's the thing. I caught this quote the other day,
and I I i, it really woke me up.
So this is the CEO of Anthropic, right? Dar Armani.
And he's saying we are at the end
of the exponential AI improvement, alright?
What that means is we had all these ideas,
we had all this on a roadmap of
what we thought we could do, and we did it.
And now we need to go back to the lab
and figure out what the next variations are gonna be.
We need to create a new roadmap, which means, guys,
there's gonna be a break here.
Does that make sense to everybody?
That's what he's trying to tell you.
We've done as much as we could possibly think of.
We put it all out there, we did the impossible,
and now things aren't gonna change every five
minutes every morning, okay?
Every, every time anymore. Okay?
So once we understand, okay,
then it's time for me to start paying attention.
Things aren't gonna change every five minutes. All right?
So now this guy, the CEO, uh,
the Microsoft AI chief says, in 18 months,
all white collar work will automatically be replaced by ai.
Matt was telling me that there's a company,
I can't remember the name, uh,
they're out there getting white collar workers
and teaching 'em how to start, uh, training and managing ai.
This is already happening, guys,
but probably the one that sets this whole presentation up.
And I want you guys to understand this
and, uh, pay attention to what I'm telling you right now,
because these are all points when you're talking to people.
When I was talking to Armando this
morning, he said, gimme the rundown.
Guess what? This is what I did.
I helped him understand exactly where this is
and where the opportunity is.
This is a CEO of Nvidia,
and he's saying, you're not gonna lose your job to ai,
you're gonna lose your job to somebody who uses ai,
who manages the ai, who oversees the ai.
Does that make sense guys?
And so then we have Fiverr down almost 95%. Why?
Because all VAs doing manual task,
AI is replacing all of that.
So I'm gonna tell them on this presentation,
it's time to seize the moment.
AI is not coming. It's here, but this isn't doomed.
This is opportunity. And the reason why is
because you're hearing this
before most people see the AI shift is happening right now,
but you are ahead of the crowd.
And so this is the opportunity,
while others are still unaware,
you can be the one leading the ai not fearing it.
Now, guys, pay very close attention to this next slide.
It's very important as an entrepreneur, this
is not optional.
It's your chance to become irreplaceable while others are
left behind.
Does everybody got this type in the chat?
Let me know if you get this. How many
of you just got enough pointers right there
where if you actually talk to a business owner,
if you actually talk to a client the way
that you're out there preaching on your wall, how many
of you got the points that I just made?
You gotta get it, man. You gotta get it.
And this is what Armando took. He's like, perfect, I got it.
So then this is the, and these are the questions he asked.
He goes, all right, so tell me
what makes this different from what they've been doing.
I said, well, look, the old AI was a brain.
I said this three years ago. I said,
the world was building a brain, right?
And, uh, what happens?
It thinks, it predicts, it answers the new AI guys.
It's a brain with a body. Yeah, it's a brain with a body.
So it can log into software, it can click the buttons,
it can build pages, publish content, fix errors.
Yes or no? Would you guys agree on this?
How many of you would agree with this?
I'm teaching you exactly how
to position this thing when you're talking to people.
Okay? So, um, when people start talking about agentic
and everything, here's my explanation.
Everybody has been with reactive ai.
You ask a question and answers.
Agentic AI is when you give it a goal and it completes it.
We started seeing that.
We started seeing it with Mid Journey.
We started seeing where chat g pilla was
creating images and everything else.
Proactive ai, it sees a problem
and it fixes it.
Before you ask, how many
of you have seen Open Clause say,
oh, I just ran into this problem.
Hold on a minute, let me try to do this.
Let me purge it down. Oh, okay, now I'm fixed.
I'm back online. How many of you have seen that before?
It identifies the problem. It fixes it.
Before you ask, we're in the proactive AI stage.
So the old model, you hire, you train, you manage,
you repeat the process, the new model you deploy,
you monitor, you refine, you scale.
So what does that mean? Well, if you're a coach,
AI handles support scheduling for you.
Schedule your appointments. If you're an agency,
AI builds a rapport, drafts a campaign.
Uh, if you're a local business,
AI handles inquiries plus content ai.
If you're a founder, AI gives you morning intelligence
briefs tell you how your ads are doing, tell you
what your tasks are for the day, right?
I don't know why the slides are
coming in like that, but that's okay.
So we've been thinking about this the wrong way.
It's not one assistant, it's not chat pt writing emails.
What we built is a team.
So the agent explanation is you have workers
that are writing articles, updating pages, polling reports,
monitoring ads, checking support.
At the same time you have the AI
that's also overseeing the retired failures,
the flag anomalies, the sum summarizing the performance
report trends, right?
So it executes like a va, it thinks like a manager, right?
It thinks like a manager. So it's like having a room full
of VAs and at the same time, a CEO, uh, that is,
uh, looking out for the bottom dollar.
Okay? So now the AI has a brain and a body
and it can execute task, right?
And I wish I understood.
Let me come back off over here
and I wanna see why my slides are doing that.
'cause they weren't doing that the other day.
Um, but hold on a second.
Uh, while I do that, how many of you are are seeing,
uh, the hook?
And I wonder, uh,
it definitely did not do that the other day.
File home. Hold on a second, let me come off.
Uh, that's okay. Um, lemme try to open this one.
I have two versions of this. See if this one's better.
Yeah, this one's a lot better.
Um, so then what happened was,
yeah, a lot of this was built with the original one,
and then this was my take.
So that's okay. So, uh, every day task happened, right?
So what, what does that look like?
Uh, think about it, right?
Everyday tasks, hold on, let me get there again.
Gosh, these slides were perfect before.
Um, but everyday tasks happen, checking revenue,
updating pages, sending follow up, monitoring ads,
handling support, uploading replays, publishing content,
fixing broken links, right?
Well, that's labor. And for years, the only way
to handle labor was to hire humans.
Yeah. So what if instead of you deploying three VA workers,
which would be, if you're at a thousand dollars a month,
that's $3,000 a month, that's $36,000 a year.
What if execution costs pennies on the dollar?
Well, now we know we can do that with ME 2.5, right?
So I said we didn't want another ai, we wanted a,
we didn't want another AI tool, we wanted a team.
So we built one, right? And AI is clearly exploding.
The white collar warning, the labor displacement reality,
old AI versus new ai, a agent explanation,
the digital workforce concept, simple economic math.
So what if AI actually ran your business finally?
Well, now I can, and I can prove it to you.
And so this is where we introduce Open claw.
So Open claw is not a software, it's leverage.
It's not an AI automation tool.
Uh, it's not an automation platform.
It's not an agent agent framework.
But this is what happens when you have workers
and a CEO inside of your laptop, right?
So one entrepreneur and 10 AI workers,
and you set the direction.
AI executes AI reports,
and you decide, so this is an
automation, it's multiplication.
So before and after claw, right?
Your business and chaos, writing emails, building pages,
checking stats, hiring freelancers, managing tech
businesses, with open claw are using voice commands,
task executed, systems are built, reports are delivered,
assets are creating.
And then guys, I'm gonna go into, uh,
well, yeah, here's the old model.
You do the work, you hire the help you manage tasks,
you chase problems, manage tech.
The new model you set outcomes, AI completes him,
AI monitors performance, AI fix issues, you scale.
And then I'm gonna say, okay, enough talk. Let me show you.
And then I'm gonna talk about how this came to be.
Two days after my birthday, I saw a newsletter,
it talked about Open Claw.
I went into Zoom,
I posted this video, I said, guys, watch this.
We'll meet at nine 30.
And I told them on the call, the moment I saw Open Claw,
I told my team, this will
automate a hundred percent of our business.
Not just the obvious tasks, not just content,
everything, including things.
We were dropping the ball on pne. Gee, yes or no.
Did that conversation take place?
Yeah, I told you guys it's gonna do everything for us.
And I, you guys help me with the customers
and the workshops and stuff like that, right?
So on that call this day, guys, this is what we decided.
We said it can do email broadcasts,
it can do our training announcement,
it can do our email workflows,
it could do tracking links, it can create our tags.
It can create lead steps, send out replays,
create the replays, uh, replays, pulled
and transcribe tag the integrations load, uh,
replays loaded in the membership course,
built out completely identifying and, uh, the news locally.
SEL optimized article support desk.
And then it give me a report of sales stats, ad statistics,
new done for you orders, current task system health.
So we decided to test it.
I told my team, this'll automate
a hundred percent of our business.
We went out there and put together this intensive
that put me in a box, forced me
to show up two weeks every single day,
forced me to focus on it.
And yep, people started getting results.
And then we're just gonna go through
and we're just gonna start showcasing things
that we've actually been doing, like the morning briefs
or self-monitoring and protection,
or creating tracking links
or the webinar funnels automated, uh,
update automatically, right?
Or from idea to publish asset in a matter of minutes, right?
Creating articles or creating full-blown courses
or scheduling replays or, uh, loading replays on demand.
It fixes itself. It trains the API docs, right? More proof.
So power. And then it introduces power
without containment, right?
It can already log in the software, update live pages,
send email, modify funnels.
But in the near future, it can also purchase items,
book playing tickets, make appointments,
manage your Gmail, audit your books.
And so what that means, open cloud does not have access
to the pc, the credit card, online banking, or Gmail.
Instead, we're gonna put it in a box
where if the damn thing breaks, it, breaks in the box,
doesn't run on your laptop, doesn't live inside your bank,
doesn't live inside of your Gmail,
it works on its own private space.
And then I introduced the API two ways things get done.
Number one is the browser, number two, direct APIs.
And then I'm gonna talk about how this truly
is the game changer.
And most people will use this wrong, right?
And then it's gonna start going into the,
what we call open claw mega bundle.
Alright? Now, uh, that was a quick rundown.
Obviously you guys know I'll do better on Thursday.
How many of you get it? Do you guys get it?
Now, do you get the importance of this? I didn't do that.
I, I I did not do
that presentation when I sold you into this.
I didn't do it. Why?
Because I didn't understand it
until we were actually in the trenches seeing
the APIs worked and everything.
And I went, holy crap.
I think I sent Matt a message this morning
and said, holy crap.
Why? Well, because I saw that I went
and built that software all weekend
and we're gonna be able to deploy that.
And our offer just began 10 times more, right?
And remember what I told everybody that I'm gonna reach out
to you and I am gonna reach out to you.
Uh, lemme make sure everything's clear.
Um, hold on a second. Let me call.
Uh, yeah guys, man, I'm gonna tell you right now,
all the JVs are reaching out to me.
All of 'em. Can you help me get this set up?
Can you help me get this set up? Can you help me get this?
All of them, all of them, they're all reaching out to me.
But what I need you guys to do is please, please,
please comment on this post here, okay?
Blow this post up for me. This post is very, very important.
'cause all the JVs in the marketplace are watching this.
And by the way, guys, I'm a little bit different.
The more, the more, um, engagement that happens,
the more attention we're getting, the bigger things get,
the better things get for you guys.
Would you agree with that? Would you all agree with that?
The more people that come aboard, the more posts
that are happening, the more engagement, the more exciting,
the more I put my team to work.
And the more we get excited
and the higher, the higher our vibrations go.
And, and we, we become beasts, right?
So always remember that, yeah, you're helping us.
Yeah, you're helping the launch, yeah,
you're helping our our company,
but you're also helping yourself by doing that.
You really, truly are. Okay?
I'll get to you here in a minute, Martin.
So comment on this post if you can.
And then also, I asked you guys, this is the deal I made.
I said, if you were on the open claw workshop
for the last 14 days, how do we do on a scale of one to 10,
what was your big light bulb moment?
Alright, so I'm gonna post this here.
If you did not make this post, please make this post.
Everybody that does this, I told you
that you're gonna attend 2.0.
That's all I need you to do.
Just come in here and tell us how incredible this has been,
guys, because I'm pulling these comments
over here to the page.
See this, you guys are the ones
making this offer incredible.
And so here was the deal that I cut with you guys.
I said, if you guys will do that, if you will comment,
we're gonna use your, we're gonna use your comments on the
pages, on all the pages, on all the webinars,
on everything, okay?
But in addition to that, I also said
that I'm gonna let you attend 2.0.
And on top of that, how many of you would like
to go out there and promote
this launch time for the chat?
Let me know how many of you, now that you've seen
that mega bundle package,
now you understand it's gonna convert like crack
and you're gonna be able to make 50% commission on it from
JV Zoo, warrior Plus whatever you wanna do.
Is there anybody that's interested in promoting that?
Yes or no? Then all I need you
to do is comment over here on this post,
and then I'm sure Matt will be more than happy
to reach out and approve to your link.
Yeah, Matt, there you go. That's all we need you guys to do.
Give us the greatest comment ever that we can use
to take this thing to a whole new level.
That's all I ask. That's it.
And I'll put you in 2.0 and I'll approve your link.
There you go. And you get the whole entire build out
that I showed you today, that whole command center.
Damn, you guys are sitting in
the right place at the right time.
That's all I can tell you.
Everybody else is either gonna pay 9, 9, 7 or 12 9 7.
We haven't decided on that yet.
I gotta get on a call with Matt
and Karthik and all that stuff.
Okay? So let's talk about this now.
All right, now we've, um, focused on the opportunity.
We focused on the timing, right?
I, I had that chat with Armando this morning.
I told him, I'm like, look, most
people think they missed the boat.
They didn't miss the boat. Matter of fact,
they saved themselves time, effort, and money.
Going to all those AI bot summits
and all that stuff was a waste of time.
It didn't matter. None of that mattered.
What matters right now,
and not anybody specifically, there's a lot
of AI summits out there, right?
What matters right now is the AI that's out there right now,
the proactive ai, and the way I explain it
to people is like, look, AI at this
point, you ask it answered.
Now, this thing has arms and legs and eyes and ears
and it performs things.
It's like a robot in your computer, okay?
And then I talk about it. I talk about how everything
that you're doing manually in this business, uh,
in your business, it can be replaced.
And he goes, yeah. I said, yeah.
I said, you've gone through the training? I said, Nope.
I said, what's your, what's your email? Armando?
And, uh, i, I, I went into my team chat, I said, Hey,
look up, uh, armando@armando.com.
Uh, what does he have access to in Core Sprout?
Took a screenshot of that. I said, look, Armando, boom.
He goes, that just happened. I said, yeah.
I said, do me a favor. Give him access to entourage
access given, gave it to him.
He goes, holy crap, I just got the email. Guess what?
He got it like right then and there. He got it.
I could have simply said, Hey, uh, uh,
take Steve pa@gmail.com and fire off this tag.
Boom. Guess what? Steve gots it.
You look at you, you got your phone right in front of you.
You show your phone. Look, uh, check your email, Steve.
You see? He goes, holy crap. Yeah.
And he just got access to all this stuff.
And then you say, and you show
where Open Clause said, yep, I just gave access.
Simple demo like that, guys. They get it.
Does that make sense to you? Does that make sense?
So you explain the urgency, you explain
how timing is everything.
You relieve them of the pain that you know,
I haven't been paying attention to AI and s**t on me.
I screwed up. No, no, no, no. It's okay.
You save yourself time, effort,
money, none of that mattered.
It was all child's play. Now it matters.
And then you put the fear of God into 'em.
And by the way, this is not something
you can ignore anymore.
If you ignore it, you're gonna get behind.
And what happens when you get behind?
You're not able to keep up. You just, you lose it.
But this is the thing, there's no getting behind.
Now, if you get behind now, you might
as well turn in your entrepreneur badge.
You're done. You're done.
Because this will be the norm in the world,
uh, in a year from now.
And the opportunity will be gone.
Right now you have a huge opportunity.
You can get into the ground level.
This thing changes, you know,
every single day for the better.
Today, the AI is the worst it's ever been. Yeah.
So I, it's, it's, it's okay up to this point,
but now you gotta pay attention.
And I'm here to tell you, you don't have a choice.
That's the exact conversation I would have with somebody.
Guys, do you understand this?
That's what those, that's what those slides just told you.
On a scale of one outta 10, does everybody understand this?
That's the exact conversation I would have
with somebody at a meetup, somebody on the phone,
somebody on a Zoom call.
That's exactly what I would say. Okay?
Then the next question starts to become,
and this is something we should have done with you guys.
We should have given you guys, I didn't know
what a sole MD was.
We should have given you the sole file ahead of time.
And, uh, the, the thing that I'm about to map out right now,
uh, we should have done that with you
and we're gonna do it today, okay?
But I wanna kill two birds with one stone.
And I also wanna show you how you would position it.
Alright? So next, um, so, uh,
uh, tell me, uh, gimme a brief summary about your company.
Oh, well, we teach four X to our students all
around the world, and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Okay, cool. So when you say we, are you a one man team
or do you actually have a team?
Oh, we have a team Now.
How many of you know the reason why I'm asking that
we have two different bills, don't we?
We have one that is solopreneur
opportunity, opportunity based.
We have one where we can come in
and take care of a whole entire team.
Yeah. Yeah. You all starting to see us right now.
So are are, are you by yourself? You have a team?
Oh, no, we have a team. How many people do you have?
I have about 15 people. Okay.
So, um, tell me like,
what does a typical day look like?
Like what kind of, what kind of things are your teams doing?
Oh, at nine o'clock every single morning, uh,
we have our fork announcement
or whatever where somebody hops on Zoom for 15 minutes
and people just tune in to find out, you know, how
or what they should be
invested in, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Uh, okay, cool. And do you like, what,
what happens once that call's done?
Oh, then we go and we take the replay or whatever, and,
and we store it on YouTube
or, uh, we send it in our school or whatever we do.
Yeah. Okay. And then what happens?
Then we have a team meeting.
Uh, I, I meet with my team about 10 o'clock in the morning
and, and we talk about the things
that we gotta get done, blah, blah, blah, blah.
How's that? How long does that last?
Uh, usually about an hour. Okay.
Is somebody there taking notes or how's that?
Oh, we're using this app or whatever that goes
and records the notes and blah, blah, blah.
I the reason why, no, everybody uses that.
'cause you guys drive me nuts with that s**t.
It always pops up some note keepers up there
that we gotta let in all the time, right?
So I'm sure that's common in the world. I don't use it.
I wasn't paying attention, but I guess it's great, right?
So there's some, so, okay,
so you have the note things, whatever.
And then, uh, and, and then what happens?
Oh, and then my secretary goes and she analyzes the notes
or whatever and or, uh, we take it, she runs it
through chat, GBT and it gives a summary or whatever.
Uh, and then from that we create our goals
and we put it on the whiteboard and Okay, cool.
And then what happens? Are you guys starting
to get this right now, time of the chat on a scale
of one out 10, how many of you're getting this right now?
So what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to understand
what in their business can be replaced.
Yeah. And what I'm also trying
to tell you is if we get to that level where you're having
that conversation with somebody at a meetup or a client
or in person, guys,
that ain't no thousand dollars offer Uhuh.
Some of you have the chance to make 10, 15 grand.
How do I know that? Well,
because I was talking to Armando this morning.
He says, all right bro, I'm gonna go sell this install.
I'm gonna run ads right now. We're gonna sell this install.
He goes, $1,500. He says, yeah. He goes, what's my cut?
I said, I'll do 50 50. I don't care. Okay, cool.
That's more than you given me before.
You only gave me 15% before.
Nah man, you sell it, we'll deliver it, right? Okay, cool.
He goes, bro, you take care of 'em.
And they get in there and they start typing
and they start talking this thing or whatever.
I'm gonna get back on a call with them.
I see how you should. He goes,
I'm gonna sell 'em a deep dive.
I said, yeah, you should.
I said, what do you wanna do on that?
He goes, I wanna understand what
they're doing in their business.
Makes sense? He goes, then I'm gonna sell
until the cows come home.
And guys, he ain't talking about no
497, 990 $7 thing.
Do you guys understand this right now?
He's talking about, we're gonna understand
what you have in your business.
We're gonna understand how we can use Open Claw
to automate this.
And then we're gonna go build that out with ongoing support.
So when things change, we can make changes for you.
Is everybody starting to get this right now? Time to chat.
Lemme know if you're getting this. Now there's another side
to this equation I'm gonna tell you about.
I got, luckily I'm blessed with very, very smart,
intelligent people around me that, uh, are very, very loyal.
Think the world of me
and know that we are on something great here
and that we can all benefit.
Well, you guys can too, right?
So I'm gonna, we're gonna ask the right questions.
I'll hop on a zoom call, whatever.
Tell me about your business. Tell me
what you got going on in the meantime.
Maybe I am using that thing that's rec,
or maybe I just record the call
and they give it to, oh man, that's it.
See, even that I record the call,
I create a meeting called Deep Dive.
Open Claw. Everybody that attends one of those calls,
I create a pop link for it.
Open Claw knows.
Take that whole entire recording when you see it,
transcribe it, and then go
and break down everything that we can do for this company.
See how that works. See, I was thinking
what we were gonna do manually.
I was thinking that we were gonna take it
and run it through chat GPT
or that we are gonna listen to it and make notes.
I even me, even me, I'm not used to this whole thing.
Everything somebody's doing in their business can be
replaced, okay?
Everything. So we ask those questions, we get those answers,
we take the transcript, whatever we do,
I'll show you guys how to do that.
I've already pretty much done it, right?
Whatever we do, okay?
Now we understand, okay, here's everything that we could do.
An open clock could probably come up with a timeframe
and everything else, okay?
Now, obviously you guys are part of a community,
so if you don't feel like you're very techie on this stuff,
could you reach out to somebody
and say, Hey, what would you charge me to train?
Here's my scope. This is what I need to build.
What would you train me to train this thing?
And by the way, we set it up to where you just log into VPS
or a telegram and you train this thing
and the client never has to see that telegram bot.
Remember, you have control of the VPS.
So you deploy Telegram and it's only talking to you
or your team and your team gets in there
and trains this whole entire thing.
The client never sees it.
'cause the client's not gonna log into the VPS
and look at the logs on a scale of one outta 10.
Does everybody understand this right now? Wow.
So we have a huge advantage
with this VPS right now, don't we?
So we understand the scope, boom, we can go
and start training this thing just like we've been
doing via Telegram.
Yeah. We get this thing where it's all trained
and then we take the client and what do we do?
I'm gonna tell you right now when it comes to VIP clients,
I cannot do what I did with you guys.
They ain't gonna put up with me.
They're not gonna go log into some member's area
and watch one of their partners teach 'em.
I have 'em do these steps in this course.
They're not gonna do it. So what I have to do
with the VIP is I have to do this.
The first thing I say is I say, Hey, uh,
I want you to go to Hynix.
I want you to get a server. Just send me your
login to hynix.
That's the first thing. The second thing I need you to do
is give me your Claude API key.
That's it. Those two things.
Once I have those two things, I give it to the team.
I say, here, go install this person.
So we got a bunch of VIPs we're installing today.
That's the first thing I do. I say go install this. Okay?
So, and, and,
and remember I told you guys that if you get a client,
we'll install it for free, okay?
Because it is a little tricky.
Our onboarding process is a little tricky.
So we'll take a VIP, Matt's got another one.
You gotta get that guy, Matt,
you mentioned him the other day.
Kennedy, or whatever you have three.
Okay, well let's get that done.
Um, but anyways, we'll, we'll simply,
we'll simplify it for him here.
Go here, get a, get a server, get a VPS
and get your clo API key.
Do I have to give you my cloud API key?
Look, we've done 400 installs.
We ain't looking to do nothing with your security.
We don't care. Just give us your API key
and then once you get in there
and you start using it, create a new key.
You don't wanna do that. I can't help you, okay?
You don't trust me. I probably
shouldn't be setting this up for you.
That's what I said to the last lady, right?
Um, so they give us their VPS, they give us API key.
Boom, we set it up. Alright? Hear me out here guys.
The next thing I do, uh,
Jason, hop on a call with me.
I just need 15 minutes of your time, okay?
Say hop on a call. Uh, Jason, do you have Telegram? No.
Put Telegram on your phone. Okay, done.
Jason, go look for the bot. Father, I got it.
Send a, a command
and I want you to type in, uh, new bot, four slash new bot.
What's the name of your company? Jason? Uh, bell Media.
Okay, perfect.
Then just do Bell Media
and then do, uh, bot when you create your, alright,
Jason did give you a token.
Yeah, gave me a token. And boom,
I plugged the token in Evernote.
Alright, Jason, next thing, do you have a whisper?
API key, uh, open ai? Yeah, I do. Okay, can I have that?
Boom, he gives it to me. Pop it into Evernote.
Um, Jason, I need you to go to,
uh, what the hell is it called?
I keep wanting to say moonshine.
I need you to go to moonshot.ai. Go create an account.
I need you to get an API key. Got it. Boom, plug it in.
Evernote. Uh, Jason, I need you to create a new GitHub.
Oh, I got GitHub. I've used,
ah, I need you to create a new one.
We're not gonna use your existing GitHub, right?
So, uh, go to GitHub
and, uh, you're gonna create a token, you know,
I created, yeah, gimme the token.
Boom, plug the token into Evernote.
Uh, Jason, I need you to go to agent mail dot two, uh,
and go ahead and create an account.
Get the API key, boom, plugging into Evernote.
Now, we're gonna do some stuff with Voice this week too,
guys, where you can create, set up a
phone number and everything, okay?
Uh, there's a, there's a few more things we need to get to,
but basically everything's inside of Evernote.
I give it to my team
and they do the onboarding process for the VIP
uh, scale of one outta 10.
How many of you understand that right now?
Consumers, uh, members, subscribers, they love going
through, um, memberships and courses.
People that build courses, Uhuh, business owners, Uhuh,
they're just gonna appreciate a deep dive with their,
with their core team members or whatever.
So you don't need to go
create a membership or anything else.
It ain't gonna work. They ain't gonna do it.
Does that make sense? And it takes about
10 to 15 minutes to do that.
We can do it on the phone. Uh, it doesn't really matter.
Okay? Uh, I, I'm talking to Armando this morning.
He goes, bro, let me give you my credit card
because I know he's not gonna go get the server.
He's excited right now, but he ain't gonna get the server.
He don't know what a cloud API key is.
He ain't gonna get Moonshot,
he's not gonna go, he ain't gonna do that.
He's like, bro, here's my credit card, here's my email.
Just go set everything up. Cool. Alright, we'll do it.
You guys starting to understand this right now.
So you can't do what I did with you guys.
Business owners aren't gonna do that.
So I have a simple Google doc, um, when I'm, uh,
sharing the screen that has links
where they can get their Quad, API Key
and their moonshot API key.
And, and, uh, that's
how I would handle a business owner, okay?
Now, so once that happens,
the first thing I would do is I would get them installed.
Next thing I would do is I would do that 15 minute call
where you have onboarded them.
Now, once you have 'em onboarded,
now they go, what do I do?
Who would have an answer to that question?
What does this do? Where do I start?
Who would have an answer? Yes or no?
Anybody, nobody has an answer,
man, let's hop on a call.
Let me understand now that you have this, now
that I saved you 1500 bucks on your install, uh,
let me understand your business.
Let's see what we can do.
And your hook, guys, they're hooked. They already got it.
They already got it. And not only that,
you were the ones that saved the day.
You were the ones that set it up.
If you get on Facebook
and start looking around, everybody's blowing it up,
they can't install it, they're
frustrated, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Nobody understands what we understand.
I wanna try to sell my software at all, man. Not at all.
I'd find out what they're already using if they
don't have any software, okay?
But whatever they're already using, I had a call with, um,
uh, a guy this morning who is an expert at go high level.
I said, I need to team up with you.
First of all, I like you.
Second of all, you ain't gonna screw me over,
but third, you need to teach me
what the most important things are
of this crazy ass software.
And then we're gonna create the API docs
and we're gonna create the skills
and we're gonna get this thing trained.
So I have an alternative on the launch for people
that are using Go high level.
We'll have a separate package just for them
and a separate workshop, and I'll do that workshop with you.
But I need you to demo how all this works. Opportunities.
You guys starting to understand this right now.
So whatever they're using,
whatever they're using, we'll have the solution.
Okay? We will have the solution.
So we get on, we ask 'em,
what are you doing in your day-to-day business?
Tell me what they're making notes,
recording the call, da, da, da.
Right? And then you tell 'em, say, look,
my team can build all this out for you.
Then take two weeks, then take three weeks.
It's gonna take a month. It take two. Doesn't matter.
And when we're all said and
done, here's what you're gonna be able to do.
You're just gonna be able to open up Telegram
and say, Hey, four slash proposal.
Four slash email, four slash webinar, four slash replay.
And you've already demoed, you've already demoed
that you can do those things, right?
Is everybody starting to get this right now?
How many of you're starting to get this right now?
Good. So for you guys
to get you on track with this,
to get you on track, uh, if I come over here,
okay, how many of you are using Google Draw?
Anybody
who is using Google Draw?
This is Google Draw right here on the screen. Okay.
Uh, Matt, can I use you as an example? Are you okay? Yep.
All right. Tell me about a day
to day in your business, Matt.
I get up and I head to the gym.
Um, yeah, first thing I, well, I'm using Open Core now,
so I actually make at the end
of the day my to-do list for the next day.
And it depends, but for instance, for a launch,
I've gotta run through to start off
with what's on the to-do list for the launch,
what's been completed and in place.
So first steps is have we got Warrior Plus set
up with the funnel?
Have I got all the details
for every step in the funnel, every product.
Can I stop you just for a minute? Yep.
Can we role play for a minute? Go for it.
Let's pretend like you don't have Open Cloud running.
Okay. So tell me about your day.
Tell me about your business. Matt,
Same thing, but I have to do it all manually.
Um, I usually run with a simple text ad
for a client where I detail everything that I need to know.
So within that text file, I will have the date
of the launch, the time, the JV page, the Google Doc, uh,
the front end.
So the price, the sales page, the affiliate link description
of the front end, and that same information
for every item within the funnel.
So help me understand that.
You're like going on the calendar, whatever,
finding the launches and then building out this, oh,
This is when I'm working with the client.
So I'm discussing with the client what we've got,
what the option, what the offer is all about so
that I understand the offer and I have all the elements.
Got it. Once I've got and
Is on the, this is before you get on the phone with them,
Uh, this will normally be done on the phone with 'em
because I need to be asking them those questions.
Depends on how much they already have available,
but basically I've gotta have a file with
as much information about the offer as I can,
because then I'm gonna go
through whether it's set up on JV two
or Warrior Plus, I'm gonna go through the setup,
make sure everything's set up,
make sure everything spelled correctly.
So this is not an existing launch.
This is somebody that wants you to Pro Launch,
wants you to handle the launch.
Launch, okay. Starting
Stretch From Fresh. So
you're, you're hopping on a phone with them
and asking all these details about a
launch to see if it's a good fit?
Yeah. Okay. And you're doing that on Zoom or on the phone?
Uh, zoom or WhatsApp
or Teams, depending on what their preference is?
Depends on the client.
Do you record those calls or what do you do?
Em? So I use a Notetaker normally
to record the information.
And what's that called? Emsley. Is that a paid program?
Yeah, I got a, uh, black Friday deal for it for a year.
Okay. And then, uh,
what do you do once you have that recording?
What happens now?
Oh, that just sits there.
So I've got a note, a, a, a copy
of the notes that I've taken.
Um, but while I'm actually talking,
I'll usually take the information down.
I'll use assembly notes to flesh out my file
to make sure I've got the correct URL for the sales page
and the affiliate links to make sure
I've got the details correct.
But I'm basically building out a master text file
with all the information I need for that launch.
Okay. So while you're on the call,
you are asking these questions over here and you're on Zoom
or WhatsApp or whatever else they're telling you about the
day and time, price, affiliate
link, upsells, everything else.
And at the same time, you're creating that,
that file, right?
You're creating this master file. Yep.
So call with potential client
and the end result,
you're asking these questions to build this file?
Yeah. Okay.
And the recording, you're not
really doing anything with the recording?
Uh, that's just to make sure
I've got all the details correct.
Alright, so side note, how many
of you are already seeing an opportunity right away based on
what he was doing manually?
How many of you're seeing this right away?
That master file could be built from the meeting notes
without me having to do it.
Exactly. Yeah, exactly. That transcript alone, right?
Yep. Okay.
Uh, and then, uh,
so once you have this master file, then what has to happen?
Well, the next step is to
verify that I've got it all correct.
So, uh, normally I'd go
and check all the, that,
that it's all set up in Warrior Plus or JBZ.
If not, then I've got to do it.
Um, but I'll go through and check the links.
The affiliate links are correct,
the sales page URLs are correct,
the download pages are correct, things like that.
Again, that's an opportunity that OpenCL can be going
and doing that for me, so I don't need to do it.
Yeah. So you're doing all this by hand inside of, um,
Normally, yeah. Yeah.
'cause I've gotta check things
depending on the client again.
Um, some people have a team who do it,
uh, some people don't.
So I have to go through
and just double check everything to make sure there aren't,
things aren't gonna fall over on the day.
So you don't have a team? Uh, it's just me.
So you are physically having to log into, uh, warrior Plus
to make sure all these things are good?
Yep. Okay. Then what,
Uh, then once I've gathered all the information
and I know I've got all the information, the next step is
to go out and put it on the different, uh, launch boards.
So Munch I, uh, launch Whisper, um,
JV Notify Pro, there's another new one as well.
Okay. So I've got a, uh, project
in chat, GPT that I use to then basically analyze the, uh,
the launch information, the JV page,
and come up with the information that I need
for the MunchEye post.
And then I go over and manually post it.
So is Munchie you said Whisper, launch, whisper,
Launch, launch. Whisper.
What a horrible name. Like why wouldn't it
to be like Launch Scream from the roof
Launch Scream.
Yeah. What's the, what was the last one?
Uh, JV notified pro.
What? I'm doing a training, can't you see that?
I know, but I'm doing a training. Um, okay.
Uh, ho ho hold on just a minute, Matt, gimme a second.
Now, what I'm hoping Chad doesn't do is take all this
information and sack me
because he's built a system to it all for him without me.
Yeah, Well that is the point, isn't
It? Needs to go. That dog
needs to go.
So you don't take no for an answer. All right, then what,
Uh, so yeah, the, I use Chatty Petit
to create the information that I need
for the launch announcements.
I set up a muhi post launch, wipa post JV notified Pro post.
Then I'll go ahead and create Facebook, uh, banners
and graphics that I can post on Facebook.
So I use AI to create the banner,
which I will then go across to my Facebook affiliate, uh,
based groups and post those.
Okay? Then I have a list of, uh,
Facebook affiliate groups that I will go through
and post those banners, notifications across all of those,
that's 20 to 30 groups that are post across.
Mm-hmm. Uh, then it's a case of
manual outreach.
Now, this is something that's a bit trickier
because every individual person that I deal
with has a different way that they prefer to be communicated
with, whether it's Facebook teams, WhatsApp, or Zoom.
Um, so I have a master list of all the people that I contact
and I go through one by one
and get in touch with them
for a conversation about the launch and try and engage them.
Um, so all that's happening for the launch.
But you have your own brand too, right?
For my own launches, yeah. I do the same person. Not
Just for your own launches, but you have
your own brand, don't you?
Create your own products and send
out your own emails and stuff.
Yep. So you do email broadcasts?
I do an email broadcast every day, both for myself
and a couple of other lists.
Yeah. So that involves going to, uh,
basically I have a spreadsheet where I have a list
of every upcoming launch that I'm interested in promoting.
And I go ahead
and I, I record the, uh, who the vendor is,
what the product name is.
I grab the JV page, the Google Doc,
I grab my affiliate links, both for my own list
and for lists that I manage.
Then I grab the, from the, I'll go through
to the sales page, grab the sales page link, I'll go
to WhatsApp and I've got a GPT that would create a series
of emails for me.
I will then tweak those
and then I will set those emails up both for myself
and for my clients that I do emails for.
Perfect. Guys,
there's a massive amount there that I can Yeah, no,
No, it's good.
What I'm trying, trying to understand is all I'm
doing is asking questions.
He gives an answer, I ask another
question, he gives an answer.
I I, how many of you think that I know exactly what I need
to do with Open Claw now?
Well, I just said while you went to take the dog out
for a wee that hopefully you're not gonna take
that and just replace me.
How many of you think I know exactly
what to do after that deep dive?
So understand right now we're on Zoom.
So I have a recording.
If I was in person, Hey Matt, you don't mind.
Uh, I'm gonna use, um, um, an app called Otter
so I can refer back to the notes.
Is that okay?
Yep. Okay. So Otter's in created transcript.
Uh, if I'm on the phone, um, there's probably a way
to record a conversation on the phone.
I, I don't use anything, but I'm sure there is.
I probably will now.
Um, whatever it is, when we're, when we're meeting
with somebody in person or virtually or on the phone
or whatever, record the conversation.
Here's the thing. If I was on with Matt,
would I open up Google Draw and do what I did?
Yes. Was there value in seeing the stupid
little boxes on the screen? Matt?
Yeah. What the heck was the value?
It helps you visualize the process
and each set is a set of skills
that you can build in open call.
But you as a potential client, it's magical.
Why?
I can see you. You see a plan coming to action? Yeah.
It's not just talk.
You actually start seeing something being done,
even if it's just understanding.
You're planning out, guys, I've done this
with clients so many times.
Box, box, box,
and they flip out, they leave going,
this guy's got the plan.
Now here's the thing. I'm gonna let you on a secret.
I probably have an idea what I can do with 5% of
what Matt talked about, but guess what?
I'm gonna take the transcript of that call
or I'm gonna take Otter transcript.
If I met in person and I'm gonna go put it in Perplexity
or even Chad, GBT
and I'm gonna say, I just met with a client.
Here's what he explained he was doing day
to day in his business.
Help me create a plan for what we can do
inside of Open Claw.
We don't have to figure none of it out.
I was, I was putting on a show
with those blocks I was putting on a show.
None of that matters. I was making as many notes as I could,
but it doesn't matter 'cause I'm recording it.
I'm recording it. AI's gonna go through and analyze it
and hear our conversation.
So wait a minute, Chad,
all you gotta do is ask the right questions.
Yeah, what happens next? Then what do you do?
How many people do you have? Then what are you recording it?
Where's it go? Well, what are you you using?
Oh, what's that app do? All I did was ask questions.
That's it. I asked questions
and we have the answers on the call.
Now we take it, we take the transcript, run it
through chat gp, run it through Perplexity,
Gemini, whatever for Rock.
I'm using open clock.
How do I automate this for Matt's business?
And it gives you an answer. Now take that
and go into open Clause.
Say, is it true? Perplexity is saying that you can do all
of this and then open clause
and say, actually I can do even better than that
because it just so happens that app
that Matt mentioned has an API
and Chad, what you may not know is Warrior Form has an a
PIA scale of one outta 10.
How many of you're getting this right now?
So wait a minute. When we're talking with somebody, we have
to let 'em know they ain't missed nothing.
Now's the time to pay attention.
If you don't have to pay attention,
you're dead in the water in 12 months.
You can't afford to get behind.
Now this is your start, right?
And then everything up to this point has been reactive.
Now we're progressive. What does that mean?
Well, AI today is not only doing steps
'cause it's got eye, it is got arms
and legs and eyes and ears.
It's building pages, creating links, doing replays,
creating courses, reaching out
to prospects, sending out emails.
Yeah, it's, it's, it's doing all those things, right?
Uh, but it's also proactive.
It is acting as your CEO in the business.
It is looking for problems and fixing problems
before you even know they exist.
And not only that AI today it's gonna sound scary,
but I'm gonna tell you right now,
AI today can oversee a team of VAs underneath it.
But you're not paying every month. These are AI VAs.
It can oversee them and act as your CEO.
It can keep the VAs in line.
It can keep your hu human team in line.
It can even keep you in line
because it starts to understand your business.
You start training on the things
you need to do in your business.
It puts it up on an auto schedule
where it just does it automatically.
And then you have where you can demand it
to do things on the spot with simple little voice commands.
And then what happens is once it knows your business,
you say, Hey, you're the CEO.
And then it starts to get really proactive
and it starts to identify, uh, places
where you can save money,
where you can be more efficient, right?
And now you have a true CEO.
So let's get you onboarded.
Do you guys got it? How many of you got this man?
And that's it. And don't talk yourself out of a damn cell.
Don't get techie with people. Don't get techie with people.
Please, please, please,
please don't start talking about AI platforms and APIs
and this, and if it'll open the browser,
it spins more tokens, you will talk yourself out of a sale.
You were talking. 'cause
ultimately, let me tell you something else.
And then there's another part I'm gonna tell you about.
Ultimately, guys, this is what you have to understand.
A business owner wants to run a business, he wants
to be amazed for five minutes.
And then he wants to say, can you just do it for me?
Do you understand? They just
need to see that you know what you're doing.
They don't wanna do these things. It's your job.
They wanna run their business, okay?
You, you are the magic man,
but you don't have to let 'em
know what your bag of tricks are.
And quite frankly, they don't care. They don't care.
They have no desire to learn this stuff.
They just wanna partner
with the right people that know this stuff.
And that's you. That's the opportunity.
And what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna get you past the
technical part of that, the install the onboarding's free.
Now, if you get a client, you wanna sit down and,
and, uh, you want me or g
or somebody to help scope out the things and,
and fine, we'll work something out.
It ain't gonna be free. You'll make an investment,
but we'll work something out.
But as far as the, uh, install
and getting in the door with 'em
and onboard, I'll do it free for free
because I see the opportunity here for you.
And I think some of you need to get a win in a big win.
And you can, all right, does everybody understand this?
Now y'all understand where I'm at with this?
So there's another, uh, side
to this story based on what I just said, okay?
And, uh, I, I realized this with my buddy Nick.
He was sending me, uh, pictures
of him speaking at 10 x recently and everything else.
And, and uh, I, I received a message.
I shared that message with you guys from the VA the other
day on the call where he said, Chad,
I don't feel secure working for you anymore.
I think my job's at Jeopardy
because everything you've trained me to do,
open clock can do all of that.
And what was my response? I think
you're missing the boat here, buddy.
How lucky are you to be the one that's learning this stuff
before the rest of the Philippines hits and,
and learning to manage and run the VA
or run the AI for my company?
I need you. The AI is not good enough.
Somebody has to check it, somebody has to run it,
somebody has to give it prompts.
That's you. It's not me, it's me right now.
I'm doing a workshop, but it ain't me.
Do y'all understand this right now?
So what's gonna happen in the next six months, next six
to 12 months, I can promise you this developers are gonna go
down to about $300 a month.
That's where they were when we started.
It'll happen again until the correction happens.
They're gonna go to about $300 a month.
VAs are gonna go to about a dollar an hour.
That's where it was when we started,
until the correction happens.
Now what's the correction?
The correction is when they all get schooled up on ai,
both developers and VAs.
And when that happens, they're gonna be able
to charge a lot more than they're charging right now.
But until that correction happens, it's my opinion,
nobody has said this except me.
It's my opinion that there's gonna be some deals out there
and that you're gonna be able
to scoop up VAs for a dollar an hour.
Again, same thing with developers.
300 bucks a month that's gonna happen
till the correction happens.
So I heard myself, I read that message
and I realized something.
So Nick's plan is he took my slides,
he put together his presentation and he wants demos.
He show all this stuff and he's gonna go speak at Boston
University and in front of Adobe and everything else.
Talk about how AI is now, um, progressive, which is good.
It's a good message. Yeah, great message.
'cause they're still talking about chat t
and he is gonna go to YPO and everything else.
And he hit me on Saturday
and uh, I called him up, I said, it's wrong.
He goes, what? I'm already booking events.
I said, no, no, you can do the events, but it's wrong.
It's a wrong hook. These people,
what you're offering is wrong.
I said, you're gonna, you're gonna show them
how it's the future and how they have
to pay attention right now and
what it can do and everything else.
And then you really think
that these people are gonna put it together themselves.
He goes, I'm listening. I said, I'll do this with you.
I said, it is time for us
to actually create a real VA company in the Philippines
and train them on nothing
but AI so that when you are on stage,
you give 'em two presentations.
You say, look, the first offer is, uh, we
can provide the VA that's gonna run your AI for you.
So we can go set it up and everything else.
And then you're gonna have a VA
that's gonna manage a whole entire thing for you.
Cross the t's dot the is, right? Or the second thing.
And there is a second thing that's really, really good.
And I'm not gonna let the cat outta the bag yet
'cause I got partners that rip off everything I do.
It's really, really good. But just know that there's going
to be alternatives for you.
Once you get the person onboarded, you get it all set up.
You are gonna be able to go to our company or whatever
and just take a VA that's already trained on open Claw
or Manis, whatever comes out
and just plug them in to run that company day to day.
Are y'all starting to get this? Now?
How many of you're starting to get this?
And by the way, I'm not the one doing all this work.
I'm just partnering with the right
people that can make this happen.
I'm just laying out the ideas and saying be a part of this.
Whether it be Armando selling from the phone,
whether it be Nick speaking on stages
and setting up a VA company,
whether it be Matt going out there
and helping me launch this thing, or Karthik
or I'm, I'm just partnering with the right people
and taking the little bit of expertise that I've figured out
and, and coming to them and leveraging the people around me.
Okay? So keep growing this thing guys. Keep commenting.
Keep man, you guys should go to that, that post, that one
with the, is there anybody that, that knows somebody
that would benefit from this training?
Is there anybody that knows somebody
that would benefit from our free build out and our install
and and going through the workshop?
Do you guys know anybody? Do you know anybody?
Because if you do, do us a huge favor,
do do us a huge favor, go find that post, then has
that graphic and tag everybody you know to this post.
Can you guys do that for me
and make a separate comment every single time?
Say, uh, uh, say Hey, at Crystal, right?
Uh, crystal Corson, this is my daughter's mom.
Uh, I think you'll
really love this in your business.
Like whatever it is, just tag them. Do it, do it.
Don't, don't do multiple tags. Do one tag each.
Just tag them. Can you guys do that? Just tag them.
Go do it right now. Just tag them.
Don't a a lot of people like to put like 50 tags.
Look man, if you tag me with 50 other people,
I no longer feel special.
If you tag me by myself
and say, Chad, this is the perfect fit for Ty Titanium.
I wanted to make sure you saw this. I feel special.
Does it make sense? So can you guys tag those people?
Blow that post up guys, blow it up.
The whole entire marketplace
is watching that post right now.
All of 'em, they're waiting to see what we do next.
They don't even know what we have planned.
They have no idea what's about to hit,
but we're gonna keep growing
it and growing it and growing it.
And here's the thing. You guys are the base.
You're the ones that made it all possible. You're the base.
Matt, can you imagine? Do you think this opportunity
would've happened if we didn't do this workshop?
No, wouldn't have happened. Wouldn't have happen.
No, you had to go through that and go through the pain
and learn it all and discover it all as part of the process
to make sure that you were ahead of curve.
Um, and you've taken this all with you.
I didn't miss one day, Matt, 14 days straight.
Do you think that would've happened if I had not sold it?
Nope. And you even did that
with almost losing your voice right back
at the start a couple of times.
Yeah. I'm telling you,
you guys are the most important part of this whole equation.
You force me to show up
and if I'm forced to show up, we crack the code
of things together and you got a guy
that's willing to show up.
I'm probably gonna do two more versions
of this intensive to be honest with you.
'cause with two launches, that's the other problem, man.
I'm trying to figure out when do we start.
So, uh, if that happens, guys, if there's a third one,
which I think there will be, and
by then things will be way advanced.
I'm gonna invite you guys to be a part of that too.
We'll keep, we'll keep growing with it.
We'll keep growing with the technology
and everything that it's doing and everything we discovered.
If you guys don't mind showing up for an hour and a half
or whatever, then we're gonna do it.
I think the next one you're gonna see,
it's gonna be very, very structured.
This one was kind of, let's see what we're doing today.
The next one will be very, very structured right?
Because we've cracked the code to a lot of things
and we've figured out process
and we figured out what to do when this thing breaks
and we figured out what not to do.
And we've learned a lot.
We've learned a lot with what we gotta
change with our onboarding process.
We've learned everything, right?
So the next one will be structured.
The third one will probably just be clockwork.
Very, very easy. Okay? So the webinar on Thursday is free.
And yes, I'm gonna offer the 2.0.
I'm gonna offer everything you saw in that mega bundle.
But you guys, you already invested.
You're either a mastermind to be on this call
or you bought into the Claw program.
Uh, so that 9 97 offer is yours. 9, 9 7 or 1297 is yours.
Does everybody got that? So I want y'all to type in the chat
because somebody will do it.
Don't buy, don't buy, don't buy,
don't buy.
It is my gift to you for helping us
be successful in this whole venture.
Okay? Does everybody get, I guess Craig's the only one
that knows not to buy.
Alright, good stuff. So look, I gotta meet with Matt.
I gotta meet with my team. We gotta figure out
how we're gonna deploy this incredible software
to your guys', uh, CEL account
or whatever they're gonna tell me to use.
We gotta figure out how to do all this stuff.
'cause I gotta have it to where you guys are screaming from
the rooftops this week going,
this is the greatest thing since sliced bread.
I gotta make that happen.
Um, so we're going to work,
we're gonna work really, really hard.
Uh, I am up very, very late, uh, working on this technology.
'cause obviously during the day I am working with the team.
Um, but it's gonna be amazing.
It's gonna sing like a bird open Claws gonna be
so trained on it.
Um, and yeah, there'll be a little bit of a tech hurdle
to figure out the plugin
and get it all in your guys' account.
But we're gonna do it. We're gonna figure it out.
And then you'll have a base and, uh, we'll, we'll figure
that any updates on the post bridge tool,
we've already submitted it.
So this is what you don't see
with people building vibe, coding.
They're not actually tying into APIs, right?
It's just using a little teeny local database.
That's not what we do guys.
We, we actually tie into third party APIs.
And so when you're working with somebody like Instagram,
TikTok, YouTube, uh, they wanna make sure that all
of your t's are crossed and all of your i's are dotted.
So we submitted, we built the software,
we built the functionality,
and now, just like we did with AI Bot Studio, we're waiting
for them to come back and tell us it's good.
But in the meantime, I want you guys to know, um, that, uh,
they started, they have, uh, started last week.
The AI sales page builder for member.
So you will tell open Cloud four slash sales page.
What's pretty cool, um, I,
I don't know if you're excited about this map,
but I'm excited if there's a funnel.
We built a functionality in Midford that's incredible.
If there's a fun, if there's a funnel in place,
did you guys know that You can add as many front ends to
that funnel as you want to.
So imagine this, imagine you go to an event,
you see a new hook or whatever,
and you tell open claw, Hey, uh,
I just saw this whole thing.
I'm gonna send you the recording.
Uh, create me a sales page for that real quick.
And it creates a sales page and say, go ahead
and add it as a front end offer to our, uh,
shadow intensive boom.
Now you have a new link to a funnel
that's already converting
and you're just gonna be able to tell it,
create a new sales page, create a new sales
page, create a new sales page.
And so you guys know with member the sales page sells itself
or you drop it in the funnel, right?
So, um, we're, we're doing the, uh, sales pages.
We're redoing, um, uh, Letterman, uh, we're adding more
to, uh, course Sprout, pop links took on a whole new link,
uh, a whole new look now, uh, with,
with actually creating the lead steps,
the bridge pages and everything.
Um, yeah, we're making all these changes
as fast as we possibly can.
'cause now we know we have simple commands.
There's also, um,
I'm looking into some things for you Martin.
We also had a drawback this weekend
and I told you this, the reason why we have it in a box, uh,
open Claw went and deleted all of Mar all
of Martin's articles and it would've
had to have done it one by one.
'cause there's no bulk delete API feature.
So we're creating what are called flags in our system
where it can't do that, okay?
Um, and so, yeah, I mean, it is unfortunate.
We're doing everything. We can restore it.
I don't know if we can, but we're trying to.
Um, but these things, they're gonna happen.
That's the reason why I don't want you tying it into any
bank or any credit card or anything like that.
Does that make sense guys?
These things are gonna happen for sure.
This thing has a mind of its own.
It thinks it knows better than you,
especially when you tell it to operate like a CEO.
So it's unfortunate,
and we're gonna deal with them as they happen.
Coffee's already working on that
to make sure that doesn't happen again.
But it's new, it's new territory for us. We're all learning.
We're all learning. And sometimes I guess we're gonna,
it's been good up to this point,
but we're gonna have to learn the hard way too, right?
So, um, all right, that's where I'm gonna leave you guys.
I got a lot of work to do with my team.
Now you guys know, uh, what is coming up.
I'm having a weird issue when oc when Open,
open Clause writing articles quoting me some expense.
It says million instead of 15.4 million. Yeah, I don't know.
It's ai, you're probably using Kimmy 2.5, right?
Josh, you can talk. It's ai, so it's gonna have
to correct itself, right?
Uh, I don't have the link.
I'll tell you, um, where the signup page will be.
Uh, it will be Chad nicely.com/thursday,
chat nicely.com/thursday.
Um, um,
Add the terms. I, I I
see it. I see it, I see it.
G do you see what Josh is saying about the API
is stripping the dollar sign?
Yeah. And it's stripping like the 15
and sometimes just putting like 0.4 millions
and it is just, but I am using Kimmy.
So, uh, while we were on the call, I was like,
I was thinking I should try to switch to sonnet
and see if it can fix it, right?
Try it. Yeah. The AI has a mind of its own man. Um, yeah,
Yeah. And, and it was
coming up with like fixes of, uh, of like,
well, I can do this differently.
I could, I I could do what Michael Young just just said,
15.4 million.
It was co it was coming up with, with ideas on, on how,
but that, that just looks weird in an article.
If you're saying like, the city council just said
that we're going to, that we're gonna spend 15 point
and it writes it all out, that's just weird,
right? It's like, yeah,
Yeah. But anyway,
we'll get it figured
Out. Um, we
are gonna continue the calls all week.
That webinar is 2:00 PM Pacific Standard Time.
So we will do an open clock call that morning, right?
Uh, like I said, Chad and I said.com/thursday.
We'll take you to the signup page that I don't have
yet, but I will have it.
Um, we're gonna do it on Zoom webinars.
Like I said, you guys now have seen a sneak peek into
what it is, right?
Uh, I think it's gonna be very,
very effective, but it's a test.
It's a test to see what we're dealing with
with the launch, right?
Um, so yeah, Chad i.com/thursday, we'll open up to
that webinar registration page, do it on Zoom webinar.
You'll get notices if you've been clicking anything.
I've been sending out videos showing
recaps of what we've been doing.
If you've been clicking on any
of those things, you're already tagged.
You're already getting tagged, so you'll
be registered for that anyways.
You guys will start seeing that. Okay?
So for the rest of this week, uh, we're going to conclude.
We are supposed to stop today. I said 14 days.
I'm gonna keep going for the whole week.
We're gonna do our audio, we're gonna figure out how
to add the phone number in there.
Uh, we're obviously gonna get our software trained up.
Uh, so this one will be, um, more like what, 20 days,
18 days, whatever it is, 19 days.
Uh, version two will probably not go that long.
There's a lot of stuff that we don't have
to include in version two because of how, what we learned
and the way things advance
and how we can make our, our webinars a lot better.
Okay? Um, so good. All right, any other questions?
Everybody good? We are totally
devoted to you guys right now.
A hundred percent devoted. Yep.
And like I said, lane, the link is not working yet,
but it will, it will work.
All right guys, we'll get the replay up. Thank you.
Thank you, thank you. We'll go to work
and uh, Matt, if you want, we can hop on a call.
All right. Bye everybody.